[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
Tag der Deutschen Einheit mag vielleicht
vielen nur noch ein willkommener
Feiertag sein der diesmal auch noch
besonders günstig auf einen Montag fällt
nicht jeder und jede will jedes Jahr
über deutsche Befindlichkeiten sie
Nieren und den Mantel der Geschichte
spüren aber der Weltenlauf will es ja
dass dieser dritte oktober in eine Zeit
fällt in der hier in Europa wieder für
Freiheit und Einheit gekämpft wird in
der Ukraine und zeitgleich in Iran
zigtausende Menschen unter Einsatz ihres
Lebens gegen eine Diktatur Aufbegehren
da bekommt das was in Deutschland vor 32
Jahren gelangen plötzlich eine brennende
Aktualität
wie in Erfurt heute diesem Teil der
deutschen Geschichte gedacht wurde
berichtet Melanie hack
es ist das Symbol einer Einheitsfeier in
einem Jahr in dem Krisen das Land wieder
verändern der Künstler mag jung hat aus
dem Logo ein Kunstwerk gemacht geboren
in Erfurt erfolgreich international ich
bin ja 85 hier geboren und dann aber
halt hauptsächlich ja nach der Wende
sozusagen habe ich das alles mitbekommen
den ganzen Prozess danach mit allen
Höhen und Tiefen deswegen ist es für
mich natürlich eine super Ehre hier das
ganze machen zu dürfen
reingeboren in die Neue Republik mit
ihren Chancen für viele andere war die
Transformation ein tiefsitzender Umbruch
32 Jahre deutsche Einheit werden hier in
Erfurt mit einem Bürgerfest gefeiert
zusammenwachsen ist das Motto
Deutschland ist eins und eigentlich geht
es in allen fast besser
und würde ich so sehen es ist
jetzt gekommen irgendwie
der einheitsprozess noch heute einer mit
Spannungen so Bundesratspräsident Bodo
Ramelow beim zentralen Festakt im
Erfurter Theater das hat auch mit
Verletzungen und Enttäuschungen und
Missverständnissen auf beiden Seiten zu
tun die viel zu selten in den Blick
genommen werden und wir brauchen viel
häufiger konkrete Ideen wie wir zu einem
miteinander auf Augenhöhe kommen können
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars erinnert an
die mutigen 89 die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger erhoben sich damals gegen die
Diktatur
immer mit der Angst dass ihr Protest mit
Panzern überrollt sie inhaftiert und
ihnen die Kinder weggenommen werden wer
heute protestiert geschützt von den
Grundrechten kann das auch weil diese
Frauen und Männer ein großes
persönliches Risiko eingegangen und für
die Demokratie und Freiheit einstanden
im thüringischen Gera etwa wurde heute
demonstriert 10.000 Menschen gegen die
Politik gegen Deutschlands Verbleib in
der NATO für Russland rechtsradikale
Gruppierungen hatten dazu aufgerufen
bewusst am Tag der Deutschen Einheit
repariere Antwort an dem der Künstler
Max Prosa geboren 1989 eine andere
Botschaft hat
wenn alle Grenzen hat der Mensch gemacht
das ist was man so leicht vergisst
schau wie ein Kind einfach in überall
es nimmt die Erde wie sie ist
das einheitskunstwerk soll jetzt auf
Deutschlandreise gehen
und dann schauen wir auf die aktuellen
Ereignisse in Iran soweit die
Informationslage ist ja möglichst die
ist ja sehr schwierig geworden sicher
ist dass Iranerinnen und Iraner in
vielen Orten des Landes weiter einen
heroischen kampfkämpfen und um Hilfe
rufen in der EU werden derzeit wohl auch
neue Sanktionen gegen das iranische
Regime vorbereitet
welche Informationen und Bilder uns aus
Iran erreichen
mutige junge Iranerinnen und Iraner
fordern das Regime weiter heraus
Freiheit Azadi skandierten sie heute in
Isfahan wir sind das Volk in Tera
selbst Abiturientinnen trotzen der
Gefahr nieder mit der Diktatur riefen
diese Schülerinnen
sie riskieren ihre Gesundheit ihr Lieben
in Teheran gestern Jagdszenen Polizei
und bewaffnete Schlägertrupps der Basic
Milizen mit Gummi geschossen und
Tränengas gegen Demonstranten 41 tote
bislang sagen die Behörden die wirkliche
Opferzahl dürfte weit höher liegen Panik
und Entsetzen gestern in der
sharifuniversität in Teheran als
vermummte Sicherheitskräfte mehr als 100
Studierende auch einige Professoren die
auf dem geländeprotestiert hatten
einkesselten und verprügelten
traininggas Schüsse schwer verletzte und
viele Festnahmen die Uni wurde vorerst
geschlossen
[Musik]
der Spitze des Unterdrückungsapparates
zeigte sich heute demonstrativ gelassen
umgeben von Militär und Polizei der Tod
der 22-jährigen massamini vor zwei
Wochen ein schmerzlicher Zwischenfall
kein Wort zu den Todesumständen im
Polizeigewahrsam stattdessen altbekannte
Propaganda Hülsen schuld ist der Feind
im Ausland
diese Unruhen wurden alle von Amerika
und Israel geplant und von den
iranischen Verrätern im Ausland
der Kampf geht um die Unabhängigkeit um
die Stärkung und Autorität des
islamischen Iran
man werde diese kleine Gruppe von
Unruhestiftern schon bald disziplinieren
so die unheilvolle Ankündigung
diese jungen Leute wurden aufgestachelt
durch solche Videos die im Internet
verbreitet werden
Videos wie diese sie zeigen wie das
Regime mit den eigenen Bürgern umgeht
ungehemmte brutale Gewalt für den
obersten Richter der Islamischen
Republik ein lobenswertes Vorgehen im
Staatsfernsehen kontrollierte er den
Familien der Opfer unter den
Sicherheitskräften andere Opfer erwähnte
er nicht einmal stattdessen kündigte er
gnadenlose Vergeltung an
besore Biene in mastom ich werde mein
bestes geben um diese Mörder und
Aufständischen zu bestrafen
gemeint waren tausende Studentinnen und
Studenten wie diese Terroristen wie
Irans oberster Richter sie heute nannte
[Applaus]
und mit Russlands Krieg gegen die
Ukraine beginnen jetzt die Nachrichten
Heinz die russische Führung hat den
nächsten Schritt zur Annexion von vier
ukrainischen Gebieten unternommen nach
dem Präsident Putin die alexion am
Freitag verkündet hatte stimmte heute
das Parlament in Moskau für Gesetze zur
Übernahme von harson und jetzt Clou Hans
konzertorisha in russische Staatsgebiet
zur gleich versuchen ukrainische Truppen
im Osten ihres Landes weitere von Russen
besetzte Gebiete zurückzuerobern in der
südlichen Region herson brachten
ukrainische Einheiten zwei Ortschaften
wieder unter ihre Kontrolle
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner hat das bis
zu 200 Milliarden Euro schwere
energieentlastungspaket für Bürger und
Unternehmen angesichts internationale
Kritik verteidigt am Rande eines
Treffens der Euro-Finanzminister in
Luxemburg sagte Lindner die Maßnahmen
sein angemessen sie entsprechen dem was
andere Staaten in Europa eingeführt
hätten Länder wie Italien Spanien oder
Luxemburg hatten kritisiert dass nicht
alle Länder die Mittel hätten um solche
Maßnahmen zu finanzieren und daher der
Binnenmarkt verzerrt werden könnte
nach heftiger auch parteiinterner Kritik
hat die britische Regierung von
Premierministerin Trust eine Kehrtwende
vollzogen die Vereine Woche angekündigte
Senkung der Spitzensteuersatzes von 45
Prozent werde doch nicht kommen teilte
der Finanzminister mit die Senkung
sollte Teil eines Maßnahmenpaketes zur
Ankurbelung der Wirtschaft sein
nach der Massenpanik in einem
Fußballstadion in Indonesien herrscht
Fassungslosigkeit im Land und es gibt
erste Konsequenzen der örtliche
polizeischiff vor der entlassen sowie
neuen weitere Beamte im ganzen Land
fanden Mahnwachen für die opferstadt die
Spieler der Heimmannschaft besuchten die
Hinterbliebenen sie sollen von der
Regierung entschädigt werden wie es zu
der Katastrophe mit mindestens 125 Toten
kommen konnte soll eine Kommission
klären
[Applaus]
die erste der erste Durchgang der
Präsidentschaftswahl in Brasilien ist
entschieden das Ergebnis knapp Sieger
ist wie erwartet der linke Ex-Präsident
und Herausforderer lulata Silva die
absolute Mehrheit konnte er aber nicht
holen er erreichte gut 48 Prozent und
muss in die Stichwahl gegen den
rechtspopulistischen
amtsinhaberbolsonaro der Schnitt mit nur
rund 5% Punkten Rückstand überraschend
gut ab und geht politisch gestärkt in
die zweite Runde Ende Oktober
nobelpreiswoche beginnt wie immer mit
der Verleihung des
Medizin-Nobelpreises und da darf sich
Deutschland heute ein Stück weit als
mitgewinner fühlen denn der Preisträger
swante päbo ist zwar Schwede aber
erforscht seit langem am
Max-Planck-Institut in Leipzig und dort
herrschte dann heute auch entsprechende
Feierstimmung
Sante pepo ist Begründer eines
faszinierenden Forschungsgebiets
vereinfacht gesagt untersucht er das
Erbgut ausgestorbener Menschenformen und
erhält damit zugleich unsere
Entwicklungsgeschichte so gelang es
pellboot zu rekonstruieren wie der
Neandertaler leibte und lebte und mit
wem sie Sex hatten nämlich mit
afrikanischen Zuwanderern der Spezies
Homo sapiens
Christina kajaz berichtet
es ist ein langer Weg der hinters wante
perbo liegt angetrieben von der Neugier
und einer großen Frage wie wurde der
moderne Mensch zu dem was er heute ist
es ist dann so oft in der Forschung dass
man nicht getrieben von deiner Art
Größen waren man denkt das müsste gehen
das können wir machen und das wird man
enttäuscht den neuen Fällen vom
sehen-weltmann enttäuscht wenn wir etwas
nicht funktioniert was macht man dann
versucht man es immer wieder ist es dann
verschwendete Mühe oder versucht man
einen anderen Weg
verschwendete Mühe war es nicht so viel
ist spätestens seit heute Mittag klar
als das Nobelkomitee den
Molekularbiologen und paleogenetiker mit
dem Nobelpreis für Medizin auszeichnete
dabei widmete er sich nicht den Fragen
der Heilkunde er untersuchte die uralten
Knochen der schon vor 30.000 Jahren
ausgestorbenen Neandertaler und erkannte
dass Sie unser Leben bis heute
beeinflussen denn in unserem Erbgut sind
etwa 2% der neandertalergene erhalten
die eine ganz unerwartete Brisanz
bekommen haben
in der Pandemie jetzt zum Beispiel die
größte
genetische Risikofaktor um schwer zu
erkranken und sogar sterben wenn man
infiziert wird von Virus kommt vom
neandertalen Menschen
sowie und anderen untersuchen jetzt
intensiv dieser
Neandertal Variante und moderne Variante
und versuchen zu verstehen was du
funktionelle Unterschiede ist und das
könnte dann zum besseren Behandlung
führen doch es geht nicht nur um
Erkrankungen die Frage die es fand der
päpe umtreibt umspannt die gesamte
Menschheitsgeschichte von Afrika aus
machte sich der moderne Mensch auf den
Weg nach Norden Europa und im Mittleren
Osten traf er auf Neandertaler und dann
noch weiter im Osten im heutigen
Sibirien auf den denissovana eine
Menschenform die Sante paybow dank der
DNA-Analyse eines winzigen Knochens
entdeckte
wie aber mögen die Begegnungen der
frühen Menschen wohl abgelaufen sein
kriegerisch oder eher freundlich swante
PayPal liest aus den alten Knochenfunden
wie es gewesen sein könnte
wir stolpern wenn man so will über diese
neue Verwandtschaften zwischen den
Gruppen
und ich denke die
Interpretation davon muss sein dass wenn
man sich getroffen hat in der vergangen
hat hat man wenig Vorurteile
gegeneinander man hat sich oft
miteinander gemischt wenn man sich
getroffen hat hat man es toll gefunden
warum Neandertaler und denisovana
verschwanden während der moderne Mensch
die gesamte Welt eroberte wissen wir
nicht es ist eine der Fragen die es
wante PayPal gern noch beantworten
möchte
[Musik]
interessant ist übrigens dass der Vater
von swantipelbo auch schon einen
Nobelpreis bekam ebenfalls für Medizin
jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz das Oktoberfest geht heute Abend
zu Ende 17 Tage lang wurde auf der Wiesn
in München wieder gefeiert
5,7 Millionen Besucher wurden insgesamt
gezählt deutlich weniger als zuletzt und
es wurde auch deutlich weniger Bier
getrunken ein Grund das schlechte Wetter
so die Veranstalter die Bilanz trotzdem
positiv nach zwei Jahren Corona
Zwangspause
und jetzt noch die Wetteraussichten
morgen im Norden und ostenteils dicht
bewölkt sonst nach Nebelauflösung eine
freundliche Mischung aus Sonne und
Wolken Höchstwerte 15 bis 20 Grad die
weiteren Aussichten ruhiges und oft
goldenes Oktoberwetter mit viel Sonne
nur vereinzeltem Regen und milden
Temperaturen von 15 bis 24 Grad
das war es von uns an diesem dritten
Oktober und mit dem ZDF montagskino geht
es gleich weiter und um 23 Uhr gibt es
dann die nächste heute Express und
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]